dolor en los hogares de los muertos y
desaparecidos en la tragedia de texas
los familiares de las víctimas lloran la
ausencia sin saber su estado real
de mexico la madre de dos jóvenes no
tiene consuelo y pensar que son dos de
mis hijos que yo con
con mucho dolor los dejé ir porque fue
bien difícil para mí
y el pensar todo lo que ellos pasaron
dentro de ese trailer
me está consumiendo por dentro y más no
saber de ellos el padre conserva las
últimas palabras que cruzó con ellos
hasta que no respondieron más
pues mis hijos no llegaron a donde tenía
que llegar
bastante
los sueños de sus hijos giovanni y ya ir
fueron truncados en busca de un futuro
mejor unos nueve mil dólares valía el
cupo para cruzar en guatemala se recogen
muestras de sangre para poder
identificar a los implicados en el
incidente la mayor parte son campesinos
no tiene no tiene un trabajo fijo por
eso los jóvenes las luchas siempre entre
inglés mente a viajar en gres y eeuu
pues ese es el motivo entonces ojalá que
el gobierno y tan siquiera busquen una
salida como ellos los temas familiares
de las víctimas esperan noticias de sus
parientes mientras tanto en san antonio
texas el conductor del camión donde
murieron decenas de migrantes compareció
ante un tribunal federal si es declarado
culpable el chófer de 45 años puede
enfrentar la pena de muerte o cadena
perpetua según el departamento de
justicia estadounidense el pasado lunes
53 migrantes perdieron la vida en
condiciones de hacinamiento el remolque
de un camión que los transportaba como
contrabando al otro lado de la frontera
sur de eeuu